(Gary laughing)
- [Gary] I love Toronto.
- [Group] Vay-ner-chuk.
- [Gary] Hey guys.
(crowd cheering)
(light music)
Hey.
- [Kevin] What's up dude?
- [Gary] What's up dude?
- [Kevin] Holy fuck.
(Gary laughs)
I can't believe it's happening.
- How are you?
- Great.
- Good, man.
- I just wanna thank you
for being you and
doing what you
fucking do man.
- Thank you, brother.
What's your name?
- Kevin Rempel.
- Kevin, thanks so much man.
- I was like, I saw the
carpet on Fairmont Royal York--
- Yes.
- You're here I'm late to the
event I'm like what are the
fucking odds that
I would see you dude.
- Thank you man.
Great timing.
- Can I give you a hug, man?
- Yeah. Of course.
Thanks for the love.
- Fuckin' unreal.
I think I love you man.
Thank you so much.
- I wish you well brother.
- Thanks brother.
- I wish you well.
See you later.
- Bye-bye.
(light music)
- Take care, good luck.
Congrats.
- [Man] Likewise.
- [Man 2] Gary, Will.
- Oh hey, how are you?
- How are you? Such a pleasure.
How are things?
- [Man 3] Gary, welcome.
- 'Sup bro?
What a great sign out there.
It's so awesome.
It's basically
everything I believe in.
Meaning it's how
I do public speaking.
It's why I won on Twitter.
It's all shareable.
You know, for me, it really won
'cause that's basically how
I always lived my life
anyway so that made it easy--
- Yeah.
- but that's it.
- But it's shareable.
- But it's shareable
because word-of-mouth
it has infrastructure.
It's called social media and
word-of-mouth is how
everything actually works.
Nobody spent, no brand has
ever spent enough money
to reach every person.
They've reached enough people
that created the word-of-mouth
that then force other
people to look for it.
Like I generally feel like I'm
playing a different bizarro game
than everybody on Earth.
I'm not kidding.
- [Man 3] Yeah.
- I just think I'm navigating
and the way I see it is like a
different color than
everybody else is seeing it.
Mainly because I think
I have two things
real-life talent and
real-life patience.
I think the people that have the
biggest skills have the ability
to not screw the other
person over every time.
They're not fighting for every
inch 'cause they know they have
it and that is, that,
self-awareness comes in all
shapes and sizes.
Self-awareness is noble and
sounds good in the way we've
positioned it so far you also
have to get into a weird place
where like if you're lucky
enough to have self-awareness
and you're good at something you
start getting into
a real place of ego.
It's a real thing.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And look, of course, I'd like
to think it's confidence 'cause
it surely is but I have to be
empathetic that I'm about to
take the stage and have a sense
of aura and bravado around me
that if people don't like what
I'm saying or if people don't
like the way I'm saying it, it's
real easy to go down the ego
path and I understand.
DRock, should we do a
quick meet up in Toronto?
How's it going so far?
- So good.
- [Gary] Good.
- It's been great.
- [Woman] So you've had a very
full and successful career and a
lot of challenges along the way.
How do you approach a challenge?
- I like challenges.
You know I'm much
more into the journey.
I look at challenges as
the narratives of my career.
The book will be very
boring if everything's easy.
You know you need the arc and
so when I see challenges I don't
think that you get to have the
luxuries that come along with
being a leader or
CEO or a founder.
If I want this, if I want the
attention, if I want the fruits
I have to be respectful that the
challenges come along with it.
I genuinely love the scene in
the movie, the cliché scene
where the person gets punched in
the mouth turns blood comes out,
spits out his tooth and looks
back at the other person like,
"Now what?"
If I was really talking to
entrepreneur just starting out
first, I would challenge
them if they actually are an
entrepreneur or they're
attracted to the current state
of entrepreneurship which
is I'm blown away by the
fact that this is all happened.
You know, I grew up in a time
where businessman and woman was
just a normal profession.
This rockstar status, this
pedestal that the entrepreneurs
been put on I benefited from it
but I'll tell you that one of
things that I want to speak
more about is there's a lot more
suicide and depression in our
world than has been bubbled up.
I've had some acquaintances
commit suicide because they were
not true entrepreneurs and when
the adversity hit they didn't
know how to deal with it because
everybody thinks everybody's
winning in our world.
And so I would tell them to know
themselves, to make sure they're
doing it for the right reasons.
I think that the entrepreneurs
that I grew up with in the 90s
and early 2000 these were people
I couldn't breathe if they
weren't doing their thing.
They weren't chasing the
headlines or the money,
it was their natural state and
I would tell them a lot about
the shortcomings
of entrepreneurship
which is it's quite lonely.
You get judged a lot and I would
poke and prod to make sure that
they had the stomach for it
because if you don't in its
current state the market tells
you everything is rosy and it's
phenomenal it's the only way.
And unfortunately, 99%
of people are gonna fail.
- [Man 4] Gary Vaynerchuk.
(audience cheers and applause)
- [Man 4] An
incredible personal brand.
We all probably know him
because of The #AskGaryVee--
- [Audience] Show!
(Gary laughs)
- [Man 4] get on your
feet and welcome
the one, the only
Gary Vaynerchuk.
- I think one is empowered
when they are at complete
peace with their decision making.
It is stunning to me how not
scared I am about anything I do.
Nothing.
Because I think that when your
intent, if you are able to push
your intent to a pretty pure
place and let me explain
what I mean by this.
I'm not fuckin' some sherpa,
Mother Theresa type character.
Here's what I think I am.
I think I believe in,
I think I believe in, you know,
meritocracy and the game
and if you're better than me,
I'm pumped for you.
See I think the problem is
so many people want to win at
somebody else's expense without
understanding that there are so
many variations of winning and
every one of us has a totally
different definition for it.
And so for me this is
been so easy this journey
'cause my intent is pure.
I want to build the biggest
fucking building in town.
I want to win, number one.
Most money, most impact, best,
best looking, you know whatever.
All that
but I want to do
it by actually doing it.
I want to build the
biggest building by
building the biggest building.
I see way too many people
wanting to build a building by
tearing everybody
else's buildings down.
(applause)
And so I feel empowered
because I feel it
comes from a good place.
I'm gonna suffocate the seven or
eight principles that I believe
in on you for as long as
you pay attention to me
and I will never change.
I'm gonna bore the living shit
out of you because there's only
so many things
that actually work.
They're just not
that attractive.
Especially right now when
everybody thinks it's so easy.
Thank you.
(applause)
I think everybody
wants the stuff,
it's just the problem
is it's hard work.
And you have to give up
leisure, family time.
Like you have to give shit
up and a lot of people just
hardwired to want those things.
We all know there's no
one-size-fits-all, right?
There's a lot of parents,
there's so many parents that
gave their kids nothing.
So much more is hardwiring
than we'd like to think.
I think it's a basic, again,
black and white thing, does the
child want to climb the mountain
of do they want to run in the
total opposite direction and
some of it, it and probably
quite a bit of it,
is a DNA game.
If I'm able to pull off a
meet-up it's gonna be around
11 PM or so I would say
realistically so...
(somber music)
So wild.
- [Group] Gary!
- [Gary] 'Sup guys?
(crosstalk)
How are you man?
- Oh my,
- [Gary] What's your name?
- Osama.
- [Gary] Osama, how are you?
- Good.
- [Gary] How'd
you guys find this?
- You really want to know?
- [Gary] Yeah?
- Snapchat, Instagram, Twitter.
- [Gary] How, what'd I put out?
- You posted a picture at
the restaurant inside--
- [Gary] And you figured it out?
- We went on Google Maps and
looked through every
single restaurant.
- [Gary] Hey.
- Hey.
- [Gary] How are you?
- I was the one who
Greyhounded here.
- [Gary] I saw your
Greyhound picture.
That's fucking crazy man.
Where were you coming from?
- I'm coming from Waterloo.
- And how far away is that?
- Yeah, it's like
two hours on a bus.
- Awesome man.
Hey, man.
- How you doin', sir?
- How are you?
Nice to meet you, man.
- Been following you all day.
- [Gary] Thank you.
- Didn't get a chance to go--
- [Gary] The conference?
- the conference unfortunately.
- [Gary] Hey man.
- Hey, how's it going?
I can't believe you're here.
(laughter)
I live like two
blocks down the road.
- [Gary] You're like
I know where that is.
I'll go. Awesome.
Well cool.
You want to take a quick photo?
I know you guys were waiting.
- Yes.
- [Gary] I need to get
back into my meeting.
I'm actually, I actually did
post this stuff just now but
I'm going back in for at least
15 minutes and
then I'll go check.
In 15 minutes maybe somebody
will show up so I'll see you
guys in a little
bit if you're here.
Thanks.
- [Man 4] Alright.
- [Gary] Yeah, I'm coming up.
- [Group] Hey.
(Gary laughing)
- [Gary] I love Toronto.
- [Group] Vay-ner-chuk.
Vay-ner-chuk. Vay-ner-chuk.
- [Man 5] Thanks brother.
- [Gary] Thank you man.
My pleasure.
Hey guys.
(crowd cheering)
- Gary, I'm Marty.
- [Gary] Marty.
- I just want to say thank you.
You and Casey from New York
have inspired me and
I'm sure a lot of people here.
- [Gary] Thank you, brother.
- [Marty] To be real, be
honest and just work hard.
- [Gary] Thank you, man.
- [Marty] I just can't
thank you enough for that.
- [Gary] Thank you, man.
- [Marty] I just
have one question.
- [Gary] Yep.
- [Marty] As a hustler,
is it okay to take
a day off every week?
- [Gary] Of course.
I take four hours off
every Sunday in the fall.
You know?
Of course.
Look, my big thing is,
and I think it's
good to have you
guys here for clarity,
I'm not so worried
if you take four days off.
I'm just worried about what
you do when you're on.
I always tell people I want
people, one thing,
that's why I did the
Arianna Huffington episode.
I want people to sleep.
I sleep.
Sleep's important.
I sleep five or six or
seven hours, not one or two.
People get caught up in the
romantic point of view
of these things.
We're all different.
The punchline though is if
you're complaining and you
aren't working as hard
as you possibly can,
that's the problem.
Everyone of these questions that
you're all gonna ask
is super personal.
- [Man 6] Yeah.
- [Gary] You know what I mean?
What am I going to tell you.
It's three weeks in four days.
That's horseshi--,
you know what I mean?
- [Man 6] Yeah.
- I think the punchline is,
I'll say it again.
I just don't understand if
you're complaining that you
don't understand that the
work ethic is the variable.
- [Man 6] No, it's not
even about complaining.
It's just should you put in a
certain amount of hustle before
you have the right to rest.
- [Gary] Of course not.
Nope.
I think work is the variable
but you're ambition may be
dramatically
different than mine.
Your variables may be different.
It's why I'm trying to put so
much context around my content
because it's dangerous to
have one-size-fits-all.
There's so many variables,
in this circle,
everybody's got
their own shit.
The only thing that
I just keep pounding is
too many people
fucking complain.
And too many people are confused
why they're not winning and so
much of it has to do
with their work ethic.
- [Man 6] 100%.
- But if you're good,
like me or your mom
or fucking the Lord
shouldn't tell you how to do it.
- [Man 6] 100%.
- [Gary] You know what I mean?
- [Man 6] Yeah.
- [Gary] The shit that
I talk about I believe.
I'm so grateful.
The thought that a human
being could get emotional about
meeting me or just desperately
wants to document meeting me is
something that I struggle not
thinking is the
coolest thing ever.
So my big belief is than money
and fame only accelerate and
expose actually who you are.
Well that was a
productive trip in Toronto.
- [DRock] (laughs)
I would say very efficient.
- We hustled.
Big fan of Toronto.
Really good day.
Great conference, a lot
of business development.
Just really,
really intrigued by,
I've always loved this city.
I've always been a
big fan of Toronto.
Just really good.
Really excited about the future.
- [DRock] Thank you.
- You got it?
- [DRock] I'll see
you in four hours.
- See ya, DailyVee.
I'll see you in four hours.
(light music)